[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today Kevin's
in Austin Texas hi Kevin how are you
Dave Jade good to talk to you guys you
too Merry Christmas hey Merry Christmas
absolutely I got a quick question for
you um so I'm 27 single I live in Austin
Texas the home prices out here are
astronomical I'm in baby step 3B I saved
up about 50,000 for that down payment
and I have about 10,000 in an emergency
fund um you're in good shape well done
oh I appreciate it thank you sir my
question is is that uh I'm still single
and my good buddy Roy has been saying
for a long time Kevin ain't no one is
going to want to datat you when you're
driving that old Honda Accord you need
to get you a sports car what your good
buddy Roy is an
idiot oh man I love Roy I really do I do
too but Roy don't know how to pick a
woman if woman is going to come to you
because of the car you drive you're not
get much of a
woman oh man I pretty much agree with
you wisdom in a multitude of counselors
I'm I'm going around um dude I was on my
third date with my wife in a 1974 Monty
Carlo and we went AC I was telling her
that some I had $2 dollar to my name and
I was telling her someday I'm going to
be a millionaire and we went across the
railroad tracks and the muffler fell off
my
car we've been married 43 years wow
she's been through bankruptcy and been a
millionaire twice riding around with
that guy with no muffler on his car yep
absolutely tell Roy not to not give any
more women advice oh man I I agree with
you on that I do but I I also have a
little bit of a bug I'd love to have
okay now we're getting to it to do with
women or Roy he was blaming on you heit
he exit
on I'm a stickler I'm a stickler and I
don't spend the money on myself like
that so I don't know is it what you try
what you got to fever for what you got
to fever for Kevin well I'd like to get
me a 2016 Camaros i' like might have
some miles on it you know something fun
sweet what's it
cost uh I I I was thinking about pulling
about 30k out of the down payment and
taking that to go get me a toy is what
I'm doing well what do you earn every
what what do you earn annually
120 all right so and you're single yeah
we've established that you're looking
for a woman yeah okay that's right um
all right so listen if you make $120,000
a year you have $50,000 in cash and you
want to delay as a single guy I don't
want to buy a house right now we're
going to delay buying a house and we're
buying a car that is used and is way
less than 50% of my take-home pay that
fits the Ramsey guidelines yeah I'm
locking in my vote I like that now you
don't think it would be cuz I earmarked
that money I put it in for a down
payment well that's why you ear mark it
so it makes you stop and think you are
trading 2 years of buying a house for
the
Camaro okay that's what this ear
markting does it makes you make that
decision and you put both of those on
the scale two years on one side of the
scale Camaro on the other side of the
scale but what you're describing is not
an outof control purchase nope unless
you're buying it to get a
girl oh yeah no I just which we've
established as a bad plan true but the
car is a sweet car there's nothing wrong
with it it's not a it's a good car I
love the car but the uh uh you know and
you know it's not going to make you
happy it's a reasonable vehicle purchase
in your situation um it is going to
delay what you're saying is I'm trading
two years of my purchase on my home goal
for this purchase of this car what are
you driving
now uh it's a 2014 Honda there's nothing
wrong wrong with it mechanically it's
Mom car about 10 grand okay so you only
really need 20
grand yeah yeah that'd be true oh that's
good look I'm excited for you enjoy the
car okay all right I appreciate you guys
I gotta pray about it wisdom in a
multitude c y one but but but don't buy
it to get
chicks you'll get the wrong chick you're
right you get you'll get one you don't
want got it shallow women are not handy
shallow men are not handy and people who
pick dates out based on cars are the
definition of shallow look it's not
going to hurt him though let's be honest
Dave oh shallow co-host I'm just saying
it's not oh my gosh it's not hurting his
case it doesn't necessarily help his
case but it's definitely not hurting his
case that's all I'm
saying women weigh in and weigh in in
those com it's not hurting him please do
not pick a date based on the car they
drive the car doesn't make them man
please car please God help us
all I'm just saying the same you're
saying if he rolls up and you know his
Honda Accord wasn't bad I don't know why
he thought that that was a Jesus card
Jesus said they're all in one
Accord right you just can't argue with
this if you wanted to buy a Tesla you
wouldn't have been on board though if he
wanted to buy a Tesla but a Tesla is not
a chick car not even close a Camaro
might be I mean not a 2016 oh yes it is
it is it it's a boss car yeah well then
that's I then I I stand my claim he is
not hurting his case he's not hurting
his case but don't let that be your
motivation it's a bad thing it's a
really bad idea if people are impressed
by what you drive instead of who you are
you have the wrong crowd you're running
with especially the wrong woman you're
dating so just you got to get P listen
that when you reach the point that
you're driving a car cuz you want the
car that's when you're making proper car
purchases when you're trying to impress
somebody a stop light you'll never meet
that's when you do stupid butt stuff
with cars you think everybody else is
looking at you oh come on nobody gives a
crap the end of day know nobody's
looking really nobody and if she's
looking I don't want her it's it I'm
just saying that's how that works and
that's official dad jokes right there
all wrapped into one official Boomer
Boomer insights and so into dating
Boomer insights Boomer Boomer dating
insights that's what that is we're gonna
have a new a new a new segment on the
show James next year Boomer insights on
dating I'm sure I'm sure we could get a
sponsor like
depends create your free every dooll
budget today the simplest way to budget
for your life